so i'm in l.a right now and me and monye
are getting our first man well his first
manny petty
are you excited i am first lady patty
i'm thinking i'm gonna get like a nude
color
so like wait do you want to pick out my
color
you can pick it unless you pick a trash
color
guys i tried this smoothie bowl it was
so trash
i was so bummed it looked so good too
the powerballs were good though
some told me that's good
i'm gonna still eat it but anyway no you
know
i could tell not the full thing
well i'm eating some of that you're
gonna take like you got like five
is going more scoops honey you know me
so well
i'm gonna do six just to spite them what
are you gonna put
[Music]
[Music]
this is the one she's doing
i like cotton candy why would you do
that to me
it's gonna look good watch
oh my god the chair massages
oh my god this is the before
are you why are you showing my feet man
what time i'm doing before and after
you're on my feet i'm insecure
yeah yeah this is the before get it i
don't see him
i put him in charge of my nails um
best decision i think i'm gonna regret
this
so i gave juanya the option to design my
nails today
i think i did a pretty good job showing
i don't i don't
know
yes this is like something i would have
got when i was 12.
i like it
how was your first nail salon experience
success
let me see show the nails yes
yes feeling like a brand new man